Speaker 1: So I want to keep talking a little
bit about vaccination and about Republican
Senator Rand Paul, Republican Senator Rand
Paul has always been sort of an odd guy, not
the person I'd go to for political philosophy
or medical advice or really anything.
He has been obsessed with badgering Dr. Anthony
Fauci and other medical experts with conspiracy
theories throughout the pandemic.
Dr. Rand Paul, yes, is refusing to get vaccinated
against covid, apparently for no better reason
than he wants to anger liberals.
So what do we know about this?
So far?
Senator Rand Paul has now said on a couple
of different shows he is not going to get
a coronavirus vaccine.
And Rand has said this multiple times.
He said it during an interview with John Catsimatidis
on his radio show on ABC 770 AM.
Here is Rand Paul saying it on, you know,
who knows some other interview that he did.
Let's take a listen to it.
Speaker 2: Have you received the vaccine yet
now that it's widely available to anybody
in the US?
Do you plan to?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I had the disease.
Naturally, there's about one hundred million
Americans who have had it.
Naturally, all the scientific evidence, all
of the studies have shown that there is long
lasting immunity from having it.
Naturally, if people want to get vaccinated,
if they're older, it's not an unreasonable
thing.
But I think for people in my age range and
younger who have had it, I think the vaccine
is superfluous.
But everybody can make their own decision
on it in a free country, everybody gets to.
So at this point, yes, I don't think there's
enough evidence leading me to think that I
need to be vaccinated since I've already had
the disease naturally.
Now, unfortunately, there is a lot at least
probably wrong with what Rand Paul is saying.
It's important to mention a lot of the things
Rand Paul is claiming to know for sure are
sort of open questions, but we have more and
more information that points actually the
other way.
So there are some extensive antibody tests
that have been done.
And first and foremost, it does appear that
the immunity you get from a vaccine lasts
longer than the immunity you get from recovering
from coronavirus.
Naturally, many studies and papers have found
this.
We're showing a screenshot of one of them
to our video audience right now.
So, in other words, there's a reason why people
are being told, even if you've recovered from
the virus still, go ahead and get yourself
vaccinated, because it appears as though we
hear about people getting covid twice.
It appears as though the immunity is longer
lasting and more robust from the vaccine than
from just getting the virus and recovering.
Now, second, again, from what we know so far
and much of this is still being studied, but
why take a chance?
It is less likely, it appears less likely
that the variants will get around vaccine
induced immunity than natural recovery immunity.
In other words, the antibodies that you have
from the vaccine are more likely to protect
you from variants.
And this means all of the major variants of
concern.
The British variant.
Of course, if you recovered from the British
variant, you'll you're well protected against
the British variant.
But big picture we have the British variant,
the Brazilian variant variant, the South African
variant, California, New York, India.
And there's probably more at this point in
time.
It appears as though if you got covid and
recovered naturally, you are less protected
against the variants than if you just go and
get yourself vaccinated.
Now, this could all be wrong, but that's where
things are pointing right now.
And so what Rand Paul is saying very casually
on multiple interviews and radio and TV programs
is counter to the best medical science that
we have right now.
It furthers vaccine skepticism.
It holds down vaccination rates, which we're
hoping for.
I mean, listen, people who want to get out
of this were hoping for vaccination rates
to go up.
And if people who are already more prone to
be vaccine skeptical, because that's what
Republicans are right now, if they hear Rand
Paul say this and then they act on that basis,
it hurts all of us.
Now, the bottom line is that this is merely
Rand Paul.
I'm talking about sort of right wing, populist
type, libertarian tinged virtue, signaling
everyone should be free to do whatever they
want.
It's all framed as being about liberty and
being about for the people.
Sure.
I'm not going to disagree with that.
But let's give them real information.
Remember that Tucker Carlson on Fox News has
been pushing a bunch of really vaccines, skeptical
stuff without saying whether he himself is
vaccinated.
We did a segment a few weeks ago.
Sean Hannity on his radio show refused to
say whether he has been vaccinated.
He actually had some very strange rant where
he said, you know, I had researched stuff
and the Johnson and Johnson vaccine was sort
of the one that was most interesting to me.
But now that everybody's saying get vaccinated,
did you get vaccinated?
Now why?
I don't want to say because of medical privacy
and whatever now it has nothing to do with
hip hop, medical privacy means hipper people
just casually asking each other, have you
been vaccinated with a vaccine that you get,
that you have side effects, doesn't violate
medical privacy, doesn't violate hip hop.
But Sean Hannity now playing coy, something
as simple as a historically effective vaccine
that will save millions of people versus just
letting the virus run rampant has now become
a politicized issue.
It's being couched by some of these Republicans
as an issue of liberty and of freedom when
it is really not what it is now for people
who like to say, because I know people will
say this, Rand Paul is a doctor.
OK, listen, Rand Paul is a medical doctor.
Now, some people will email me some anti vaccine.
This is so weird.
Antibiotics, people will email me and they'll
say, you know, David, you should really highlight
the work of doctors who are saying you should
not get the vaccine.
And then I look and it's OK.
It's a Ph.D. It's like a doctor of education.
It's a we're talking about medical doctors.
Rand Paul is a medical doctor.
That is true.
He has training as an ophthalmologist and
eye doctor.
He hasn't been board certified since 2011.
And I love my ophthalmologist.
I've had the same one for 30 years.
I don't go to him for epidemiological questions.
I don't go to him for questions about infectious
disease when there are so many experts in
the field, including one we interviewed yesterday,
Dr. Isaac Voguish from the University of Toronto
and Toronto Hospital.
So for anybody who's going to email me and
say, but sir Rand Paul is a medical doctor,
OK, save the email, I don't need it.